hello and welcome to the new world
review where we're going to smack you
over the head with some big ol knockers
door knockers that is because we want to
bring some hunter hunter direct to your
lounge room or bedroom
or bus stop or like wherever you are
hiskey bisky
gun and friends are here to help you on
your way if you enjoy my new name for
the show i review give me a thumbs up
and subscribe
if you think hunter hunter deserves a
different name like two kids and a
swinging fun time
drop a comment down below right now
though it is time to discuss episodes 66
and 67 episode 66. in this episode we
went back to the beginning of the show
and kilauea did his favorite thing
shopping no one knows where or how kilwa
acquires all these outfits
no one knows how he so often looks like
he belongs in the
height of fashion in paris thing is the
first time almost literally the very
first time it could possibly have been
explained logically within the game
he came out with the very same vest he
went in yep he was in a clothing store
why didn't he vamp his look why didn't
he jive with the turkey birds and walk
the runway before heading back into the
game
he could have got himself a new snapback
cap a new jacket even a skateboard
nah he wandered in and wondered out
throwing the possibility of an
explanation for where he gets his fancy
new digs
right in my face and you know what i can
respect that it shows character growth
and maybe that he's paying attention to
the mechanics of the game
the point of giving up items in a game
is that you no longer have the thing
does that mean he'll never have the
clothes he had before i mean the season
has
changed kilowatt probably
ritualistically burns the clothes he has
after wearing them once
he seems the type to do that after all
he's kilwa
denizen of darkness defeater of every
single other person taking the hunter
exam so he can be the only hunter that
comes out that year i know i said i
wanted it over with quick
but i really didn't expect it to be over
quite that quickly
i wonder whether the fact that there are
more people taking the exam this year
will be of particular importance
knowing that tagashi tends to take us
into random places based on the singular
thought he's having only at that one
time i'm going to say probably not but
then who knows
i thought we were done with the neon arc
but the fact that she can't do her
creepy fortune telling ghostbuster thing
is an indication that he's roping more
things in
i also thought we were done with the
crawler arc but here he and sookie
are messing things up again how and why
hisoka's in the game no one knows
and why cruella is of importance is
actually kind of interesting to me
but like how and why why what are we
tying into here
the pieces of this weird puzzle don't
add up yet between the absurd trading
card game that's going on mid-story with
okay look his name is says says
percussion man and the bummer the
flicking through of spell cards that
still disconcerts me and the sort of
ongoing story
i don't entirely understand what's going
on yet it's like there are two entirely
separate threads of conversation
and they're tenuously connected by a
desire to be the one to finish the game
on the one hand we've got the previous
arc with the phantom troop hisoka gone
and kilwa and a pending meeting of
hisoka and biski though i really expect
them to already know each other given
their respective ages
on the other we've got the whatever it
is going on between the noobs wanting to
finish the game they're not noobs really
but i get the feeling still that it's
going to be very very easy
for gone and kilwa to just punch out the
three card collectors they have no real
reason to hurts
percussion man but we know they would if
they stop gone reaching his goal
we already know why hisoka wants to help
crolo he wants to be able to fight him
and apparently his fortune said to go
east toward a mysterious island
but sookie's also in the game so he can
accept a schwing of appreciation toward
god and kilwa when he sees or senses
their new
and expanded abilities i wonder whether
hisoka's schwing is
like a compass schwing over here schwing
over there
i found them the power of the lock on
schwingable that sounds like merchandise
if ever i heard one that's the merch i
would buy for this series
like a schwingable compass yes i would
take it thank you
i will have three three let's talk about
dice it's not
really very well known but i am a
tabletop gamer which means i play games
with dice
lots of dice liam tries to stop me
buying dice but i
am a dice goblin
that face kilauea got when he was about
to roll again on a d20 to see whether he
would be lucky was very familiar to me
the reaction biski had knocking him out
to stop it happening
was also familiar but no one will stop
my dice horde from growing
no one in fact between writing this and
recording it
i purchased more dice the fact that
these dice
they've acquired can actually be that
dangerous is something i can truly
connect with
that said i find it really interesting
that tagashi couldn't just stick with
one style of game
in true to gashy way he decided that in
his video game there would be an entire
card game mechanic with a side of dice
in there just to make things interesting
the problem is that in making things
interesting my main issue is that
people i.e me get lost in some of those
mechanics
then again i suppose i'm also proving
that maybe it gives audience members
something else to hold on to
because i like the pretty rocks and i
really only
am focused right now narratively on how
the pretty rocks work either way
i'm glad to see the click black rocks
turn up in a game and i'm excited to see
what happens when one of our
protagonists runs out of luck
more the idea that the bad luck
encompasses every single positive role
is quite a fascinating concept that i'd
like to
excuse me while i go do a little design
research because that's
fascinating anyway let's take a look at
episode 67
more cards but this time at least
they're using the cards and getting used
to them
the point of the card use here is what
i'll focus on and that point is that
now they're physically strong they need
to become strong as
mages because they're in a game and this
is an rpg so we have to assume that they
are wizards they are now
magical strong fighter wizards i just
have to say the trading of cards feels
really tense for the people involved as
god's response showed last episode but
as not a card gamer it is actually
seriously difficult for me to be
interested in the concept of
the trade of a piece of paper or card
particularly by
antagonists of the side quest sharing
the luck in this case was the only way
to try to amp up the tension involved
but
it still didn't really i wasn't tense or
holding onto my butt in any way because
i'm not i don't think all that invested
in the aspect of
show or narrative that is winning greed
island
not yet at least maybe i will be
eventually and this is all set up but
it's not it's not immediately gripping
me and i'm really really hoping there
will be payoff but if the auction
mini arc is anything to go on i don't
think it will be strong enough to
cover the engagement fee here it's not
that i can't comprehend the idea of a
great race sort of situation just that i
have no real connection to the
importance of it can the game only be
completed once in all the mechanics i
feel like i
don't really know this if it can only be
finished once sure
god and kilwa have to beat the others
before they get there if not why the
rush
why the push wait no everyone wants the
5 bill
5 billion 50 billion jenny people want
money and apparently also
says get says which makes very little
sense to me
is he just there to provide more tension
is he there because he was always
supposed to be or did takashi just like
his eyebrows
and by the way here we go again with
more people underestimating our kids at
this point i get that it's going to
happen every time but i really don't
know that we need to go through it at
this point
what i really what i would really like
is for there to be
very little discussion about the issue
at all and to have gone and kilauea and
biski at this point prepare to do the
thing they hate every time
which is explain exactly why there are
kids in this apparently elite group of
people who can collect cards just fine
and for someone to say
no actually they've clearly managed to
make it this far without being killed
how what did they do how do i become
more like them
teach me sensei what's the deal with
having to use a very specific spell to
get it to a specific town
with a specific number of people and
talk to a specific person to get a very
specific event
that's slightly more than improbable
rather than just
heavily unlikely they now have to enter
into a group match to win things
specifically at that point yes i'm
saying specifically a lot
i'm incensed specifically
at that point they're getting cards but
if only one can win
ultimately will they go back into the
hunter game hunter games
hunger games style cull will they have
to get rid of everyone else they've met
and discuss the situation with
speaking of everyone else they've met
here we go again we need to talk about
tagashi
and boobs we have had three different
examples of boob focus that i can
remember
the first one was during the exam where
they magically drew the eye
the second time they managed to stay in
a jacket with so much hold
that i assume they must just be drawn on
and here we have boobs that have their
own
physics literally their own physics
they did not respond to gravity if
anything they defied gravity
is that one of her powers because those
things were intensely floaty
it's a hundred percent the most
memorable thing about that character
aster i mean i even made a note of her
name because her boobs deserve their own
character
astor boob one and astaboob too maybe
astaboobs
now that i've boobranted for a bit i'm
glad they ended up sharing information
and essentially forming a team but it
looks to me as though they already have
a rat in their midst
for someone to say a situation is brutal
it feels as though he has the intention
of telling others something is happening
or where and how it's happening
given how hard it was to get hold of
this game the people who are turning up
seem to be finding it really easy to get
in and out
i'm not sure how i feel about that but
since we haven't been in the real world
for some time i guess i don't really
need to worry about it there's just
something very odd
about the exclusivity of a game an arc
ago suddenly having this huge population
whose plans are only just coming to
fruition now especially since some of
them are distinctly weaker than our
protagonist and wait
what happened to the dude with the
creepy monster on his shoulder why does
tagashi not keep me updated about these
characters
what's kurapika up to we can assume
leorio studying but what's kurapika
actually doing what decision did he make
you can't feed us a tiny piece of
information then fail to give us
anything else
i want more fit more story in damn it i
could do with more story and less
playing cards if i'm honest but that's
just me and if that annoys you it's fine
because that's it from me
if you enjoyed the discussion here in
the wormhole that we slipped into
feel free to click here here and here
for more of the same
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to see more great content
i need a nap bye